[Music]
there seems to be a
considerable overlapping recognizing
these differences
in your opinion when does the left go
too far
uh uh in uh
let's see a number of ways especially
the contemporary left
has tended to gravitate toward identity
politics
toward seeing um
debate and analysis of social issues in
terms of the relative
power of different ethnic groups and
races and seeing
social progress in terms of rectifying
an imbalance between whites and blacks
or
men and women as opposed to recognizing
discrimination that has occurred but
striving toward a society in
which people are evaluated based on
their individual rights and their
individual merits
so identity politics and with it a
a relativistic epistemology that says
that
your opinions are determined by your
race your gender your sexual
orientation your handicap status as
opposed to their
internal consistency and uh support by
evidence i think there's far too much
hostility to
um markets into capitalism on the left
just given the historical and
a contemporary record of which societies
one would want to
live in north korea versus south korea
west germany versus east germany
venezuela versus
uruguay for example
let's see well those are oh i i think
the um as i mentioned before
uh the uh uh hostility
uh among the left to rule of law and uh
law enforcement is uh uh inconsistent
with their role of policing
in reducing violent crime uh that'd be
another issue that the left i think has
lost touch with um with facts
uh the importance of
market economies in elevating societies
from extreme poverty
the fact that uh global extreme poverty
has declined by 75
to the last 30 years largely because of
liberalization of market economies in
countries like china and vietnam and
india
so those are a number of issues in which
i think the
the left has uh gone off the tracks
but the certainly the contemporary
american right is far worse
the the trumpet right in um
uh denigrating international agreements
and norms which are increasingly going
to be necessary to
confront global challenges like climate
change
the hostility to any form of
regulation even ones that
would be justified by a market-friendly
mindset such as pricing harm
to the environment which even if you're
a staunch capitalist you realize the
market itself
uh will not uh take care of
the um indifference to the
uh the the plight of people who can't
contribute enough to a market economy to
support a decent way of life uh the
the difference to the to the poor to the
sick uh to the elderly and therefore a
rather
ideological opposition to all
forms of government assistance to the uh
to the needy
we just know again there's nothing that
dictates that you have to be hostile to
social programs if you're sympathetic to
markets because it's just a
basic of of uh analysis of markets that
they don't
provide for for the poor so unless you
just
are happy to let the poor starve and die
of disease
you have to have markets you have to
have mechanisms
that the market doesn't provide and this
is hardly radical even if you are
a free market libertarian
you